good morning and good to you today I
loved your video last week about how
especially in online discourse we often
create dichotomies that place us into
one of two opposing camps like two
innocent examples being a hot dog is or
is not a sandwich or cereal is or is not
a soup one might call these questions
instantly debatable and of course they
do extend beyond the hot dog and cereal
realm but the thing about these
instantly debatable questions is they
tend to avoid nuance and complexity like
there is a spectrum of foods that
involve some combination of processed
wheat with meat and or cheese and or
vegetables and within that Spectrum
there is another spectrum that we call
sandwich and both of those Spectra have
fuzzy edges because that's the nature of
Spectra but that is a boring take that
does not demand engagement whereas a
question like is butt legs does demand
engagement and engagement is sort of the
fuel that runs the social internet
videos with higher engagement to view
ratios on YouTube or Tick Tock are shown
to more people than videos with low
engagement to view ratios the same is
true for example on my Twitter like here
are a couple of my recent tweets this
one a joke about the former prime
minister of the UK got 20 000 likes and
generated over a hundred new followers
this one shares the news that Sierra
Leone's kissy psychiatric hospital has
just been accredited as a full teaching
hospital where for the first time in
Sierra Leone's history Physicians and
nurses can get psychiatric training
inside the country and it got about five
percent as many likes as the Liz trust
won and generated zero new followers now
obviously these are very different
tweets one is a celebration the other is
a joke one is about a news story
everyone on Twitter knows about the
other isn't but I see this everywhere I
make stuff online when I make something
that allows people to agree or disagree
with it in a straightforward dichotomous
way it gets a larger audience than when
I don't do that and this is true even
when I'm sharing something that almost
everyone would be happy about like that
the Sierra leonean Healthcare System is
getting stronger the only real way I've
found to get a lot of Engagement around
an issue that people basically agree
about is to present it as instantly
debatable as in this is obvious and the
only reason it's not happening is
because systems or people are merely
evil and corrupt the most notable
example of this in my own life is
probably my long-standing crusade
against the U.S penny and I can get some
engagement out of the idea that the U.S
penny only gets minted because Congress
mostly cares about divisive issues that
can help them get reelected and not
super obvious things like not minting
pennies however that kind of thing is
much easier with small issues like
pennies than it is with something big
like the multi-factorial Injustice that
has led to impoverished health care and
education systems but here's the thing
even though vlogbrothers videos about
how stupid pennies are have gotten lots
of Engagement and Views I would actually
argue they have been less effective at
making change pun intended than
vlogbrothers videos that get far less
views for instance vlogbrothers videos
about kisi psychiatric hospital and for
me that's the real lesson the way to get
simple engagement likes views comments
is not necessarily the way to get actual
engagement the kind of volunteering and
fundraising and lobbying that helps
bring about real change of course none
of this is to delegitimize having fun on
the internet and engaging with instantly
debatable questions and I think even
politically charged instantly debatable
questions can be hugely helpful in
getting us angry because we should be
pissed off about Injustice and sometimes
those instantly debatable questions can
be a way into a new or deeper
understanding of it the year I graduated
from high school 11 million children
under the age of five died this year
fewer than 5 million will that is still
way too high but there was nothing
inevitable about that progress it
happened because people worked together
to make it happen activists healthcare
workers governments Charities all work
together to make that progress and it
was messy hard complicated work but that
is real engagement not stopping at mere
despair Hank I'll see you on for Friday